so with uh
you know logan paul of course is like
such a uh
just epic like landmark moment in
history when you
and logan paul thought both times and uh
i get you know what i think i i'm
curious to know and i really don't know
is there any like sort of bad blood is
there any
beef between you guys um
i think i think there's just a high
level of respect
there's always going to be respect there
but you know i don't think we'll ever be
friends if that makes sense
i think if you ran into each other like
at a party would it just be like oh hey
man
it would just be really awkward yeah
really awkward yeah
like i think it would just there'll be a
lot of tension like
i don't think we would just stop each
other and go oh what's up man
i know i like i wouldn't go over to him
and i don't know well what do you think
about his brother calling out dana white
no no no no no yeah brother man
i can't [ __ ] his brother no no i hate
jake with my passion
it's so funny though like i saw from
dana weiss he said that was uh
i was the video game kid from england
right
i saw how so funny but he follows me on
instagram who do you know
yeah right i mean i love we
we are such humongous fans of the ufc
there's just like
i mean like we we worship the ufc i do
not
ever miss a fight i [ __ ] love it and
with that said
i you know i hear you're saying i hate
jake paul and i get it like he's so
uh polarizing so abrasive but dude the
the i don't even i can't believe i'm
gonna say this
but like his firing back
at dana white his like he's kind of good
at what he does
like yeah but he hasn't he hasn't been
tested
yeah oh yeah but definitely not dude
definitely like nate robinson ran into
we literally ran into him and got
knocked out like no one
fight no that's not how the fight it
went dude like
nate robinson i mean yeah
you make a good point that for him to
say like oh dude come on man who's next
like
yeah yeah let me let me fight conor
mcgregor now what
yeah that's the next step
doesn't make any sense right that's like
fighting someone who's disabled
and then going yeah okay i can fight uh
dwayne johnson now let's go let's do it
all right
oh oh let me let me fight khabib now
right
i mean what are you doing making sense
in that regard it's awful but then went
like just
being like sort of uh a troll he's good
at that
he's he's he's good at it i think
getting under people's skin he's good at
it
you know i mean obviously yeah but i
feel like that's easy
you know like that's easy to do it's so
easy to be fun if you wanted to be
a [ __ ] it's so easy
yeah dude